[Music]
at this very moment in the depths of
earth's oceans alien lifeforms are
waiting not alien in the sense that they
come from another planet but alien in
the sense that they're so different from
what we think of as life they seem not
of this earth and if our oceans harbor
organisms that appear extraterrestrial
imagine what we'd find in a literal
alien sea
polynices is a speculative biology
project by the brilliant artist and
world builder jj aniorte which explores
life on a planet ruled by aquatic
organisms the infinite forms of this
tropical paradise are among the most
creative i've ever featured on this
channel pushing the boundaries of life
as we know it there's a tremendous
amount to discover and as always you can
follow and support the artist using the
links in the description
so let's dive into these teeming waters
and see what awaits us upon planet
polynices
the planet of polynices is dominated by
a global ocean that surrounds the
planet's sole supercontinent conditions
on land are harsh due to solar radiation
and brutal aridity yet just below the
waves life is overflowing
beginning in the tropical shallows we
can find the stegocaudate one of the
most emblematic groups of polynices
at a glance we seem to have found the
fish of this world yet stegocaudate like
all life forms we'll discover on this
planet are actually something far
stranger colonial organisms on earth
colonial organisms are life forms that
are in fact made of many different
individual organisms working in tandem
to survive like organs in our bodies
different individual organisms which are
called zooids have different functions
from locomotion to digesting food to
reproducing and the zooids that make up
the stegocaudate are no different with
each individual organism playing a role
in the survival of the larger life form
in order to understand this way of life
we must follow a stegocaudate from its
birth to its death as larva stegocaudate
are transparent and lack the distinctive
body shape of adults as they grow older
their shell which is at first covered by
a thin layer of tissue becomes more
prominent as the tissue fades away
the end result is a highly unusual life
form with exposed digestive and
reproductive zooids enclosed within a
fish-shaped shell while an alien
organism taking on a shape similar to
earth fish might be surprising the laws
of hydrodynamics have shaped non-fish
animals into fish-like forms before in
our own oceans this was the case for the
filiro a genus of marine mollusks with a
body plan and style of locomotion almost
identical to fish the shells of
stegocaudate are exceptionally light
allowing them to swim freely they can
also extend digestive zooids out of
their shell to vacuum up debris that get
entangled in the cavities of their body
a fascinating life form indeed after the
death of a stegocardiate its light
hollow shell usually reaches the coast
with the digestive zooids faded away
this skeletal frame has washed up on the
shore of the supercontinent as on our
own planet death is a central part of
life on polynices
yet while they live the stegocaudate
thrive often taking on the kinds of
bright hues we associate with tropical
fish on earth in particular they can be
found in shallow reefs which extend for
hundreds of miles across the sea floor
in certain areas these reefs are made up
primarily of hive sponges an unassuming
yet highly unusual life form we'll
discuss shortly before we do there's a
life form that clings to the reefs which
demands our attention this maze-like
organism is a type of onirocholia a
taxon closely related to the
stegocaudates their digestive zooids
grow in far more sinuous in intricate
forms than their relatives creating
patterns that are completely surreal to
look at most onurocolia remain
stationary throughout their life relying
on filter feeding for sustenance
some genuses however take to the seas
like their stegocaudate relatives able
to control their buoyancy thanks to
internal gas bladders these labyrinthine
organisms float along like balloons and
can feed on a wider variety of life
forms
a far more fish-like classification of
colonial organism can be found in the
common amphinatins these intriguing life
forms don't possess visible shells and
swim in small schools similar in
composition to many schools of fish on
earth yet while amphinatins might look
like fish at first glance breaking down
their biology reveals they're actually
quite distinct their eyes are located in
the center of their body with two on
each side evolved from ancient digestive
zooids they give amphenadines 360 degree
vision furthermore their hidden mouth is
located underneath these eyes and is
connected by the folds of the mantle to
two siphons on their front and back
these siphons can suck in food and
release water for a jet propelled escape
across the coastal reefs different
amphenadines have distinctive diets the
hive sponge eaters are a notable group
that feed almost exclusively on the soft
tissue of aquatic hive sponges due to
the narrowness of their siphons they've
lost the ability to use them as a jet
propulsion organ although the siphons
still possess a tremendously powerful
suction force to aid in consumption
their patterned skin breaks their
silhouette on the reefs a type of
camouflage convergent with many types of
earth fish and when an amphinadine is
spotted by a predator they can take off
in either direction since their bodies
are symmetrical they can swim forwards
and backwards easily retracting one pair
of fins and using the other to propel
themselves along
and there is one region in particular
where amphinatins thrive the barrier
reef of cannos metropoli is the largest
reef system of polynices extending over
11 000 miles or 18 000 kilometers here
hive sponges reach a breathtaking level
of size color and diversity some of
these colonies are almost 10 000 years
old and their nests can span several
hundred square meters as a result for
the infinite and sponge eater kano's
metropolis is practically paradise here
the amphinadines have a veritable buffet
of sponges that extends in every
direction a seemingly limitless source
of potential food yet as we'll soon
discover the sponges aren't entirely
defenseless
the hive sponges themselves might be
completely stationary when menaced by a
sponge eating predator however most
types of hive sponges have an unexpected
defense they can release swarms of tiny
lifeforms called drones into the water
which descend upon predators to defend
their home
under magnification it becomes clear
that the tiny drones possess sharp mouth
parts which can irritate predators that
swim too close to the hive in many
respects the aquatic drones have
converged on a behavior similar to that
of earth bees not only do they defend
colonies with their stinging strikes but
they also collect food for the hive
sponges in the form of planktonic
organisms
yet perhaps the most incredible aspect
of the hive is that it communicates with
its drones through radio wave
frequencies specialized structures which
are actually highly derived drones
themselves serve as signal repeaters to
transfer signals from the hive to drones
that travel long distances in search of
food as incredible as this likely sounds
it's possible that brittle stars a close
relative of the starfish can detect
radio waves and might even use them to
navigate their surroundings although
studies are ongoing it seems this is
possible thanks to specialized
structures along their cell membrane
that function like tiny radio antenna so
the radio wave communication of hive
sponges while unexpected is far from
impossible radio waves don't travel far
underwater so a wide variety of
biological receivers have emerged to aid
in getting signals to the drones
get other lifeforms on polynices have
taken radio communication to even
stranger levels in the larger taxon of
radioscriptorians
the chainfish are organisms unlike any
other these life forms are characterized
by having a body divided into three or
more modules that swim in an orderly
line while they appear to be unique
individuals they share the same genetic
information and cannot live without each
other therefore although they are not
linked by any type of tissue they are
considered a single organism as stated
before colonial organisms in our oceans
are indeed made up of many different
types of living units working together
although they're typically connected by
some kind of tissue but for the various
types of chain fish connectivity comes
once again in the form of radio waves
these bizarre processions communicate
and sense each other's position entirely
through short range frequencies and so
the chain fish move along the seabed
continuing their bizarre way of life
and throughout the global ocean perhaps
the ultimate realization of radio
communication comes in the form of a
larger network that is emerged between
individual sponges using complex
frequencies hive sponges can send
signals to each other including
information about their environment
calls for help or even stimuli like pain
that other individuals can experience as
their own
this intercommunication has over
millions of years led to a complex
evolutionary arms race producing
adaptations like the encryption of
messages passwords and even the sending
of deceptive signals this biological
internet is an incredible feat of
evolution and something unique to planet
polynices
in speaking of unique another
unprecedented life form exists in the
form of dipteronathes as larva these
lifeforms seem to have two heads but
their mouth is actually located in the
middle of their bodies which is
connected to two independent stomachs
located on opposite ends of their figure
as they get older these twin digestive
systems drag out behind the head like
tails connected to the body by long
pharyngeal ducts this strange body plan
arose from the fusion of two digestive
zooids but today all three regions are
controlled by a single brain
in coastal lagoons warm and calm waters
provide ideal locations for
dipteronathes to flourish this
particular specimen is an echinocephalus
characterized by pharyngeal ducts that
can reach almost one and a half feet or
half a meter in length while everything
about the dipteronathes is somewhat
bizarre they are a highly successful
albeit highly specialized form of life
in this region this environment is also
home to distinct varieties of hive
sponges which form impressive reefs on
the
seafloor and nestled among reefs like
this one a bizarre filter feeder is
waiting this is a sea belt a distant
relative of the hive sponge this
organism is formed from a stationary
hive and hundreds of drones joined
together by suction cups forming a
structure similar to a circular ribbon
the belt constantly rotates so that each
drone passes through the interior of the
hive and deposits plankton trapped
during the spin the living hive then
digests this plankton and transforms it
into a nectar that feeds the drones
truly there's no other organism like it
other organisms get around by very
different means rhodograta is a diverse
class of life forms that traverse the
seabed by rotating themselves via
contractions of their muscles this form
of locomotion has earned them the common
name of sea wheels each individual zooid
in the larger wheel possesses two legs
which look a bit like the spindly legs
of earth millipedes unlike millipedes
however sea wheels have no true front or
back with every zooid on the wheel
having their own simple mouth as a
result which mouth gets used depends
entirely on which section of the sea
wheel is closest to their prey on a
given hunt and so the wheel spins on
feeding upon whatever lies in its path
along the rocky shore of the
supercontinent we can find something
exceedingly rare for planet polynices a
creature that can move upon dry land
this massive life form is a colony of
carnivorous fear and gopods which work
together to drag the serpentine body of
the colony out of the water to catch
prey in puddles along the shoreline a
pair of simple eyes located at each of
its ends provide simple visual
information that facilitates navigation
in this environment the flexible
appendages that the colony uses to get
around resemble the two feet of sea pigs
an unusual type of sea cucumber that
walk along the floor of our oceans on
tube-shaped appendages yet the thousands
of tentacular appendages on the
underside of the intertidal colony
aren't just feet but are actually
individual zooids with mouth teeth and
stomachs and at almost 10 feet this
shambling goliath is one of the largest
and most dangerous predators in its
environment
and at last the final life form on
planet polynices we'll be discussing is
the lai margia one of the most
recognizable organisms in the polynices
reefs this bottom feeding life form is
adapted to engulf sand and digests the
organic matter found in it playing a
very important role in the ecosystem by
recycling nutrients the most impressive
characteristic of limagia however is its
size
some species of the genus can reach
almost 200 feet or 60 meters in length
making them without a doubt the most
massive polyzoens as incredible as the
sounds some of the absolute largest
earth siphonophore colonies do reach
similar lengths in the deep sea although
they can't quite match the lamargia's
size in possessing such incredible bulk
the enormous bodies of limagia serve as
a habitat for a plethora of organisms
who find refuge upon its trunk as a
result the lai margia resemble a moving
landscape steadily shifting across the
sea floor
the waters of polynices are home to some
of the most surreal forms of life i've
ever documented for the archive even the
most alien organisms in our oceans
aren't quite as surreal as what swims
below those waves if you've enjoyed
learning about the complex creatures of
polynices you can follow and support the
artist using the links in the
description an art book exploring more
about this amazing planet will be coming
sometime in the future so keep an eye
out
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you